Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Du, die Pfalz heißt gar nicht Pfalz. Das heißt Palz.
Ach so, und das sagst du mir jetzt, weil ich das nicht wusste, ne?
Musik,
Logbuch-Netzpolitik Nummer 534 vom 30. September 2025.
Ja, das heißt nämlich gar nicht Pfalz.
Das heißt Pfalz. Die Pfälzer sagen das F nicht. Wusstest du das?
Nee.
Wieso wissen wir überhaupt so wenig über diesen westlichen Teil Deutschlands?
Da ist schon so Das ist ja das Unknown, unknown,
Ich meine schon, das Saarland ist das totale Mysterium, ja, aber eigentlich
fängt das alles schon in der Pfalz an Pfalz, meine Güte, die haben es doch jetzt mehr,
Ja, ich gewöhne mich da langsam dran.
Also ich hatte, ich weiß, dass in den Shownotes auch Pals-Lied stand und ich
dachte, das muss ich wohl falsch geschrieben haben.
Aber dann meintest du auch noch, das heißt Pfälzer-Lied und ich dachte,
ja gut, wenn er meint, der wird ja wohl wissen. Ich habe ja keine Ahnung von der Palz.
Und dann suchst du das falsche Lied raus. Und wir haben die halbe Palz in den
Kommentaren. Drei, vier Leute haben sich auf jeden Fall...
Ja, das ist also mindestens ein Viertel Saarland ist das.
Ja, also damit sind wir schon beim Feedback angelangt. Ja, also Chris schreibt...
Hallo und erstmal danke fürs Teilen der Geschichte von Bad Dürkheimer Wurstmarkt.
Obwohl ich in der Pfalz wohne, oder heißt es Palz?
Palz, er wohnt doch dort, der weiß doch, warum er das ausspricht.
Schreibt aber Pfalz.
Ja.
Seid ihr die Ersten, die es mir berichteten? Na bitte.
Allerdings ist euch ein Fehler passiert, den ich richtigstellen muss.
Es geht nicht um ein Pfälzer Lied und zum Beispiel das Lied,
was ihr abgespielt habt, das könnt ihr ja textlich auch verstehen. Vielmehr geht es um das.
Oh, falsch geschrieben.
Ja, weil da steht Palzlied sozusagen. Also das ist auch das,
was mich so verwirrt hat. Ja, also die schreiben da selber Palzlied.
Anyway, also es geht um das Palzlied von den anonymen Gitarisch... Gitarischte.
Die anonymen Gitarischte. Die anonymen Gitarischte.
Die schreiben alle nicht richtig, beziehungsweise Autokorrekter,
die wahrscheinlich auch einen reingehauen. Ich schreibe wahrscheinlich auch
Pals-Lied und dann wird das einfach vom Auto korrekt auf Westdeutsch übersetzt.
Genau, also einer Mundart-Band aus der Pfalz, die wie ich lernen durfte aus
Frankenthal kommt und die irgendwie wohl auch so ziemlich die einzige Mundart-Band
ist, die dann eine besondere Bedeutung hat.
So Görn und so, da gibt es halt so Höhner und sowas.
So was ist das. Ist das singbar? Auf jeden Fall.
Zum Beispiel ist es fester Bestandteil jedes Heimspiels des 1.
FC Kaiserslautern und wird dort zelebriert.
Ja, der Pelser Buu, fügt noch an, jetzt geht es los.
Der Pelser Buu, das Pfälzer Heimatlied ist heutzutage in der Pfalz nicht mehr präsent.
Und das Palslied, hier ohne F,
hat in den letzten 20 Jahren den Platz der inoffiziellen Hymne übernommen.
Die anonymen Gitarüste sind in der Pfalz, oder heißt es Palz,
allgemein bekannt und auch die einzige bekannte, jetzt schreiben die immer Pfalz,
Palzrockband, jetzt nennen wir das einfach so.
Im Gegensatz zu anderen Regionen wie Köln gibt es nicht so viele pfälzische
Mundartlieder, höchstens noch die alten vom Liedermacher Kurt Dehn.
Zum Wurstmarkt in Bad Dürkheim, der Camp.
Das ist das größte Weinfest der Welt. Daher wird in der Stadtverwaltung niemand
gesagt haben, holt mal Bier, sondern eher halt einmal meine Rieslingsschorle.
Okay, also habe ich auch noch einen Fehler gemacht. Natürlich.
Du bist nicht perfekt, Linus.
Na, nur weil du da mit dem mit dem Palz...
PS. Es gibt viele hübschere, kleinere Kerven und Weinfeste in der Pfalz,
falls mal jemand vorbeikommen will.
Zum Beispiel in Deinesheim oder einem der Dörfer von Neustadt.
Genau. Über 600.000 Leute kommen da auf so ein Weinfest. Das ist ja wie eine
Hannover Messe. Industrie.
Eine Weinindustrie-Messe ist das quasi.
Hast du gesagt über 600 Leute?
600.000.
Achso, okay. Ich dachte bei der Hannover-Messe ist aber ganz schön.
Eingebüßt mit der.
Zeit.
Das ist so das, was zu CeBIT normalerweise kam. Ich weiß nicht genau,
wie lange das Wurstfest läuft.
Das wird dich jetzt überraschen, aber für Alkohol interessieren sich mehr Leute als für Computer.
Ist ja nicht so, dass auf der Hannover-Messe kein Alkohol floss.
Und da war er sogar kostenlos. Meistens.
Jaja, also Dürkheimer Wussbach. Wir haben also eine Menge gelernt über die Parts.
Ja.
Aber wir haben es ja eh mit der Aussprache. Das kommt auch schon im nächsten Kommentar wieder raus.
DK schreibt zum Thema irische Datenschutzbehörde.
Erstens, da das Thema eventuell noch öfter vorkommt, zuerst zu dem Namen der neuen Kommissarin.
Die schreibt sich N-I-A-M-H Sweeney. Und ich habe natürlich Niam Sweeney gesagt,
weil ich keine Ahnung habe.
Das ist ein irischer Name und spricht sich wie Niamh aus.
Ja.
Gut, Neve Sweeney, meinetwegen. Nicht, dass man diesen Buchstaben das ansehen würde.
Ne, aber das haben irische Namen ja an sich, dass die einfach komplett anders
geschrieben werden. Also erkennbar anders.
Da wisst ihr ja auch selber, dass das anders geschrieben ist.
Genau, und Wales und so weiter. Das sind wirklich die morigsten Sümpfe der Sprachwissenschaft.
Der Phoneme.
Phoneme, Phonetik, genau. Phonetischer Sumpf ist das.
Und den phonetischen Sumpf kann man sich einfach nur verlaufen,
egal ob es Irland, Wales oder die Piles ist.
Ja.
Zweitens, dann zur Genese der IT-Branche in Irland. Ihr bekommt meiner Meinung
nach immer wieder die Reihenfolge durcheinander.
Nach meiner Erfahrung sind die Gründe, warum die ganzen US-Tech-Riesen in Irland
angesiedelt sind, ursprünglich andere. Nämlich erstens Zugang zum EG- bzw.
EU-Binnenmarkt, zweitens Sitz in einem Land mit Englisch als Amtssprache,
drittens niedrigere Steuern, viertens preiswerte und gut ausgebildete lokale Arbeitskräfte.
Soweit ich weiß, waren das die Gründe, wegen derer sich die Tech-Unternehmen
in den 80er, 90er und Nullerjahren in Irland niedergelassen haben.
Da spielte der Datenschutz noch keine Rolle.
Es war meiner Meinung nach so, dass die Tatsache, dass die ganzen Tech-Unternehmen
in Irland waren, die irische Regierung dazu veranlasst hat, den Datenschutz
möglichst nachlässig zu behandeln.
Für die Ansiedlung war er ursprünglich aber kein entscheidendes Kriterium.
Ja, das kann man, glaube ich, mal so gelten lassen. Wobei, ich glaube,
mittlerweile ist es ein Anlass für die Ansiedlung in Irland.
Ja. Und ich bin ja auch, also gab es diese Unternehmen denn da schon?
Naja, also manche sind schon ziemlich lange da. Also ich glaube,
Apple ist da wirklich schon ziemlich lange vor Ort.
Aber das ist ja auch schön und gut, weil wir sprechen ja eigentlich über Facebook.
Und ich weiß ja, ob Facebook sich in den 80ern, 90ern dort niedergelassen hat.
Also Facebook Aber der entscheidende Satz ist ja,
es war meiner Meinung nach so, dass die ganzen Tech-Unternehmen Weil sie in
Irland waren, die regierische Irung dazu veranlasst haben, den Datenschutz möglichst
nachlässig zu behandeln.
Ja, also Apple ist da schon in den 80ern dahin und da gab es natürlich noch
kein Facebook, also konnten die natürlich auch noch nicht dahin.
Okay, aber für die Ansiedlung, gut.
Und dann hatten wir mit mehrfachem Hinweis, dass ich mich dafür nicht interessiere
und keine Ahnung, habe es nur
zur Kenntnis genommen, habe von diesem Fall einer Julia Ruß gesprochen,
die dazu kommentiert, A, klar, also die Sendung ist erst dieses Jahr gestartet
und wird vom NDR und BR zusammen produziert.
Julia Ruß war ursprünglich die einzige Moderatorin.
Nach drei Pilotfolgen wurde entschieden, dass zwei Personen moderieren sollen.
Eine für den NDR, eine für den BR. Die produziert ja schließlich auch zusammen.
Julia Ruß ist, anders als ihr sagt, nicht zum BR gewechselt. Sie war schon da.
Das heißt, Sie hat dort ab 2020 ihr Volontariat gemacht, arbeitet seitdem dort
und wird den BR-Anteil der Sendung auch weiter moderieren.
Ich verstehe die Aufregung daher nicht. Das ist doch bei neuen Sendungen normal,
dass man nachjustiert. Dafür macht man das ja mit den Pilotfolgen.
Bei jedem anderen Job hat man auch eine Probezeit. Gut, aber bei jedem anderen
Job kannst du die Probezeit nur entweder bestehen, aber nicht so halb.
Ja, du hast sie nur halb bestanden, wir geben dir eine halbe Stelle. Aber, ähm, ja.
So ist es.
Naja. Okay.
Kommen wir zu den schönen Themen?
Kommen wir mal zu richtig. Hier, pass auf, Julia. Jetzt erzählen wir dir mal
einen vom Cancel. Jetzt kannst du mal sehen, wie einer gecancelt wird.
Und nicht nur die halbe Sendung oder sowas.
Naja, jetzt wird zurückgecancelt hier. Also wir berichteten,
dass auf Druck der Trump-Regierung und FCC der Fernsehsender ABC sich dazu entschlossen hat,
die Late-Night-Show von Jimmy Kimmel live aus dem Programm zu nehmen.
Und das hat dann doch eine etwas, ja, eine größere Protestwelle gestartet,
hatten wir uns ja hier schon drüber unterhalten.
Auch auf die Option hingewiesen, dass man ja zum Beispiel, weil ja Disney der Owner von ABC ist,
ja doch dann einfach mal ein bisschen mit der Geldbörse abstimmen kann.
Und so zum Beispiel so ein Disney Plus Account kündigt oder Hulu und was sonst
alles noch zu diesem Konzern gehört wie ESPN.
Stellt sich raus, das scheint wohl eine ganze Menge Leute getan zu haben.
In einer Woche hat also Disney 1,7 Millionen Subscriber verloren.
Das mal so locker das 4- bis 5-fache von dem, was normalerweise da irgendwie cancelt.
Und das war dann wohl so teuer,
dass sie nach 5 Tagen klein beigegeben haben Und mittlerweile ist Jimmy Kimmel
mit seiner Late-Night-Show wieder on air und hat auch entsprechende Einschaltquoten erhalten dafür.
Sehr sehenswerte Sendung, können wir auch noch verlinken.
Ja und das war es dann auch schon wieder mit guten Nachrichten,
das war jetzt noch nicht mein Jingle wert, weil auf der anderen Seite geht es ja gleich los mit Trump,
der dann die nächste Attacke ja schon lange gestartet hat.
Unter anderem hat er Facebook und auch Twitter verklagt gehabt wegen seiner
Accountsperrung anlässlich dieser kleinen Revolution,
die er da versucht hat zu starten am 6.
Januar nach seiner Abwahl.
Und die Stürmung des Kongresses, des Kapitols.
Und jetzt hat er natürlich geklagt und mit dem Argument, das wäre ja hier freie
Meinungsäußerung und das ging ja nun überhaupt nicht. schon sehr lustig.
Also so Jimmy Kimmel und die ganzen anderen Late-Night-Hose,
die sagen wir mal so für das aufgeklärte linke Amerika stehen.
Also die dürfen sozusagen nichts Böses sagen, aber er darf halt irgendwie so
einen Regierungsumsturz moderieren und kriegt dafür dann eben auch noch Geld.
Denn wie schon mit Twitter, als auch mit Facebook, hat er sich nun auch mit
YouTube geeinigt auf einen Vergleich.
Sprich, YouTube zahlt jetzt einfach 24,5 Millionen US-Dollar quasi als Schutzgeld
an den Mafia-Boss, damit da irgendwie Ruhe ist,
weil sie wahrscheinlich befürchten, dass wenn sie da noch gegen weiter vorgehen
und am Ende vielleicht sogar noch Recht bekommen,
dass die Trump-Regierung sich dann halt anderweitig an ihnen rächen wird.
Ja, so viel Geld in etwa haben sie auch schon von Facebook bekommen,
von Twitter gab es irgendwie 10 Millionen, also es läppert sich.
Die Monetarisierung der US-Präsidentschaft schreitet voran und so ganz nebenbei
wird dann eben auch noch der ganze,
Medienzirkus auf Linie gebracht, sodass die mal immer schön tun,
was jetzt der Präsident möchte und das ist natürlich alles sehr beunruhigend.
Ja.
Und weißt du, wer die Kohle kriegt dann so richtig? Also die kriegt er ja nicht direkt,
sondern die fließt dann in den Trust for the National Mall,
das ist halt die Organisation, die unter anderem gerade diesen neuen Ballsaal
baut, den Trump jetzt irgendwie im Weißen Haus errichten will,
weil ja, weil sowas brauchen wir ja wahrscheinlich.
Es ist wirklich so volle,
Kanone, Idiocratie und schlechter Geschmack. Es ist wirklich irre.
Man kann echt nur hoffen, dass er seine Präsidentschaft nicht komplett durchziehen wird.
Ja, sie drehen ja jetzt, also übrigens wurden ja dann auch YouTube-Accounts,
die wegen falschen Informationen zur US-Wahl und zu Covid gesperrt wurden.
Das wurde dann auch mal direkt wieder aufgehoben.
Ja, also es lohnt sich in dieser Zeiten,
sich mit den Wirkungen und Machtgefügen von Massenmedien auseinanderzusetzen
und sich damit zu beschäftigen, ja, was...
Also was du dafür, also auf wie viele Gehirne gleichzeitig du damit halt einwirken kannst.
Und wenn du jetzt sagst, alles klar, pass auf, ihr müsst die Rache fürchten,
wenn ihr euch mit dem Präsidenten anlegt oder wenn euer soziales Netzwerk irgendwie
von Elon Musk gekauft wird und da neue Inhalte bestimmt werden.
Aber davor werden die ja noch nicht mal, das ist jetzt nur so der Teil,
wo sie dann ans Geld gehen.
Das nächste wird ja dann sein, wenn jetzt, dann werden sie halt an die unabhängigen Dinge gehen.
Bin auch mal gespannt, wie lange das dauert, bis ihnen nichts mehr einfällt
und sie, was weiß ich, gegen Apple vorgehen, wegen irgendwelcher Trump-kritischer
Podcasts im Verzeichnis oder so.
Also du kannst natürlich als.
Regierung, wenn du diesen schlechten Stil fahren möchtest,
enorme Informations- und Medienkontrolle vornehmen und natürlich auch ein Bild
schaffen der Normalität, die nicht so gegeben ist.
Wir haben damit viel Erfahrung in Deutschland mit den Erzeugnissen des Springer
Verlags und der Leute, die beispielsweise sowas wie die Bild-Zeitung publiziert haben.
Was war das bis jetzt ein paar Jahre her, dass der Julian Reichelt,
der ja nun wirklich für die Aufgabe wirklich ungeeignet ist.
Also der ist ja nun, also ernsthaft hat der halt andere Probleme.
Dann wurde der gegangen, dann kam doch ganz kurze Zeit irgendwie einer von der
Süddeutschen, ich habe schon wieder ganz vergessen, wie der heißt,
der da irgendwie halbwegs seriöseres Fahrwasser da reingebracht hat,
also für Bild-Zeitungs-Niveau.
Er hätte es auch schon schnell wieder weg gewesen. Ich weiß nicht,
ob der ein halbes Jahr gemacht hatte oder so. Dann wusste da wieder ein Hetzer hin.
Nur wir haben das bei der Bild-Zeitung, nimmst du das Problem ja ein,
immer weiter abnehmend war.
Weil es ersetzt wird durch soziale Medien, YouTube-Müll, Facebook und Sonstiges.
Mir ist übrigens auch aufgefallen, ich beobachte es an mir selber,
dass ich früher schon sehr viel Zeit auf Twitter verbracht.
Und glücklicherweise habe ich mich eigentlich meiner Social-Media-Sucht irgendwie,
da hat nicht so wirklich was nochmal bei mir auf dem Niveau verfangen.
Ich hab da diese Mastodon-Sachen und alles so, aber irgendwie war diese Mask-Übernahme
von Twitter dann so, das Ding, was mich da einfach wegvergrämt hat und ich irgendwie
auch gemerkt habe, dass ich jetzt nicht wirklich was vermisse, ganz im Gegenteil.
Same hier.
Aber ja.
Geht aber nicht den meisten Leuten so. Sondern es hängen schon immer noch alle
an diesen Kanälen und diese Entwicklung zeigt natürlich wieder einmal mehr,
wie schwierig eben eine Medienkonzentration ist.
Also wenn wenige Unternehmen entweder sehr große Outlets kontrollieren oder
wie man das an anderer Stelle hat, wenn es halt einfach Unternehmen gibt,
die entweder wie YouTube selber sozusagen so eine große Nutzermasse repräsentieren
oder eben Unternehmen alles mögliche aufkaufen.
Und da gibt es ja in den USA zum Beispiel, so Sinclair ist ja so ein konservativer,
eingestellter Medienkonzern, der vor allem so diese ganzen Local TV Stations
owned in den USA und auch teilweise eben die Ausspielung von ABC und anderen
Sendern dann unter seiner Kontrolle oder im Vertrag hat und die haben dann zum
Beispiel diesen Jimmy Kimmel auch erstmal nicht gespielt, so haben sie dann.
Das kann man mittlerweile auch sein lassen, aber grundsätzlich hast du das Problem,
entweder werden halt diese Unternehmen
einfach gekapert von irgendwelchen Leuten, die, weiß ich nicht.
Sinistre Einstellungen haben,
siehe so Elon Musk oder generell halt Fox News mit der Murdoch Family.
Oder du hast vielleicht so, naja, so halbwegs Unternehmen, die noch davon träumen,
nicht evil zu sein, die sich das vielleicht auch mal selber ins Motto geschrieben
haben, die aber dann einfach aus finanziellem Druck sozusagen,
in die Enkel getrieben werden, weil dann so eine Regierung daherkommt und sagt so, naja,
hier schönes Medienimperium habt ihr da, aber wäre ja mal scheiße,
wenn euch jetzt die FCC anfängt, am laufenden Meter die Beine unterm Arsch wegzuziehen
und Und da haben sie natürlich dann alle Schiss vor.
Und dann ist das Geld mal ganz schnell wichtiger als irgendeine Non-Evilness
oder Meinungsfreiheit oder sonst irgendwas.
Das verschwindet dann halt sehr schnell.
Das ist natürlich dann ein Argument für alternative Netzwerke.
Aber die haben natürlich nicht im Ansatz dieselbe Pressure. Die Leute hängen
einfach rum bei Instagram.
Die Leute hängen rum auch teilweise
noch bei Twitter. Aber viel wichtiger natürlich mittlerweile TikTok.
Wo sich so die Jugend mittlerweile total drauf eingeschossen hat.
Mir persönlich immer noch ein Rätsel, aber naja, ist nun mal so.
Und man sieht ja auch, wie das Gefeilsche und Gebuhle bei Trump um TikTok geht.
Überhaupt wird die amerikanisch-chinesische Auseinandersetzungsachse,
glaube ich, in Zukunft noch eine sehr viel größere Rolle spielen.
Weil so in zehn Jahren, denke ich mal, ist China so weit,
dass sie auf, nicht vielleicht nicht auf alle, aber zumindest auf sehr viele
große, bedeutende Strukturen und Unternehmen und Dienste, die üblicherweise
in den USA zu Hause sind, dass sie da betrachten.
Eine Antwort drauf haben oder dass sie da zumindest eine Alternative haben.
Nicht nur jetzt in China selber oder im asiatischen Raum, sondern eben wie wir
das mit TikTok gesehen haben, durchaus auch mit weltweiten Appeal.
Naja und die Kohle und die Motivation ist da und die politische Kontrolle ist da natürlich auch da.
Und da steht dann so Europa so ein bisschen wie so ein Zuschauer am Netz auf
dem Tenniscourt und guckt nach links und guckt nach rechts und guckt nach links
und guckt nach rechts, aber er kann eigentlich nicht wirklich eingreifen.
Ja, dann gibt es natürlich, wir haben es in der letzten Sendung schon besprochen,
dass es angekündigt wurde.
Einen Tag später hat dann auch das Weiße Haus eine Anordnung veröffentlicht,
in der Trump die Antifa als militaristische,
anarchistische Organisation bezeichnet, die zum Sturz der US-Regierung,
der Strafverfolgungsbehörden und des US-Rechtssystems mit gewaltsamen Mitteln aufrufe.
Deswegen handelt es sich um eine inländische terroristische Organisation und
deswegen würde man jetzt eben ermitteln gegen die Antifa und organisatorische
sowie finanzielle Unterstützer.
Ja, gleichwohl, ich glaube, wenige Tage danach haben sie gesagt, okay,
der nächste Einsatz bewaffneter militärischer Kräfte im Inneren wird dann jetzt in Portland passieren,
weil dort inländische Terroristen die Einrichtung der Einwanderungsbehörde EIS gefährden.
Und das hat er festgestellt und ja, entsprechend kann sich jetzt Portland darauf
freuen, dass du nicht nur diese Eis Goons, die da ja irgendwie ja im Prinzip.
In Uniform und ich weiß, ich habe jetzt nicht genau gesehen,
ob die bewaffnet sind, aber die auf jeden Fall sehen halt einfach bewaffnet
aus, ja wahrscheinlich, also der rennt in den USA schon
unbewaffnet rum, das kannst du ja gar nicht machen, also wahrscheinlich sind
die bewaffnet, sehen auf jeden Fall martialisch aus und picken sich irgendwie
bei Gelegenheit irgendwelche Leute mit einer Hautfarbe, die nicht dem Farbschema entspricht,
und zerren die dann weg oder so.
Und das ist natürlich, das gibt natürlich, das kannst du nicht lange machen,
bis du Unruhen provozierst und wenn du sagst, diese Unruhen müssen aufhören,
dann hast du eben, dann stellst du das Militär daneben.
Und dann hast du natürlich, das ist ja das, was hier jetzt auch.
Ja angestrebt wird, das wird natürlich auch Ärger geben.
Ja, also natürlich wird eine Bevölkerung, der die ganze Zeit in ihren Amendments
und in ihrer Verfassung davon erzählt wird, dass es ja sehr sinnvoll wäre,
wenn die Bevölkerung bewaffnet ist, damit ihr die Regierung nicht allzu sehr
auf der Nase rumtanzt, damit sie sich quasi gegen eine feindliche Übernahme von oben wehren kann,
dass die, wenn ein Militär da reinkommt und alle sagen, wir brauchen hier kein
Militär, dass die sich dann auch provoziert fühlen.
Da kannst du ja Gift drauf nehmen, dass du Idioten findest, die in diese Falle reinrennen.
Viel klüger wäre es ja, wenn ganz Portland einfach nicht mehr zur Arbeit geht
und sagt, wir trauen uns nicht mehr raus, weil da draußen Militär ist.
Dann wäre das sehr schnell weg, weil die Portlander Wirtschaft innerhalb kürzester
Zeit dann da am Arsch wäre.
Aber ich schweife ab, Die Antifa,
die Organisation Antifa, da kann man ja bestimmt irgendwie eine ladungsfähige
offizielle Adresse finden, wo sich das Hauptquartier befindet und dann dort
die Verantwortlichen irgendwie verhaften.
Nein, kann man nicht, weil es die Antifa als Organisation ja gar nicht gibt.
Ich glaube halt, dass genau das Ziel dieser ganzen Sache ist.
Eine Idee, nämlich die Idee, sich gegen Faschismus zu engagieren, in Verruf zu bringen.
Und also stell dir mal vor, wie oft du das Antifa-Logo siehst allein,
es gibt ja viele Leute, die haben das auf dem T-Shirt, weiß nicht,
gibt es keine Ahnung, manchmal ist das irgendwie auf einem Getränk mit drauf,
auf einer Getränkeflasche das ist ja schon ein wirklich sehr weit verbreitetes,
universell bekanntes Logo,
und wenn du das einstufst als verboten oder als,
Zeichen einer terroristischen Organisation,
verfassungsfeindlichen Organisation oder so, dann kann natürlich auch niemand
mehr dieses Logo tragen, ohne erwarten zu müssen, dass er irgendwie sofort verhaftet wird.
Das wäre irgendwie so, du siehst ja zum Beispiel auch im deutschen öffentlichen
Raum sehr selten das Symbol des islamischen Staates,
weil eine Terrororganisation ist und du damit sehr viel Ärger auf dich ziehst, wenn du das trägst.
Und das machen die natürlich hier, oder das wird die Konsequenz sein für die Antifa.
Oder für jemanden, der sagt, ich betrachte mich als Antifaschist.
Ja, was ja nichts anderes heißt, als der Staatsform des Faschismus stehe ich kritisch ablehnend,
Oder sogar vehement kritisch ablehnend gegenüber.
Oder sogar im Weg.
Oder sogar im Weg. Und ich weiß auch nicht, wie du ernsthaft sagen möchtest,
ich betrachte mich als Demokrat mit der Präferenz für eine bestimmte Staatsform,
die demokratische Prinzipien hat.
Aber ich bin jetzt nicht dringend Antifaschist. Wir könnten ja auch einen demokratischen
Faschismus machen. oder so. Also das ist ja,
Genau.
Absurd ist das.
Es ist wirklich absurd. Und dann hast du aber natürlich in Deutschland auch
noch so Politiker wie Jens Spahn, der natürlich so also,
der Jens Spahn mit den Maskendeals und dem Häuserdeals und so der ja,
der sicherlich auch dann irgendwann, wenn er mal an die Macht kommt,
noch ein paar juristische Ermittlungen gegen ihn niederschlagen muss und irgendwelche
Sonderermittler irgendwie,
in den Knast bringen muss oder so.
Der sagt dann, der betrachtet dann irgendwie Charlie Kirks Ansichten als in
erster Linie sehr klar und meint dann irgendwie, ja,
die ganze Zeit wurden ja, die Linken haben ja hier die ganze ist halt gecancelt,
jetzt wird halt mal zurück gecancelt oder so.
Also der reitet auf solchen Ideen dann mit.
Und das ist natürlich, also es ist sehr, sehr.
Und es gibt zum Beispiel einen Unterschied, wenn die sogenannten Linken oder
die Antifaschisten sagen,
ich glaube, es wäre mal jetzt an der Zeit, ein AfD-Verbotsverfahren einzuleiten.
Ich wäre mir sogar sicher, dass dieses Verbotsverfahren Erfolg hätte und wenn
das keinen Erfolg hätte,
dann verspreche ich mir als Demokrat eine positive Wirkung davon auf die Partei
und auf die Demokratie als solche.
Also könnte ja sein, das war jetzt gerade ein Zitat.
Und wenn dann ein Trump sagt, hier übrigens terroristische Organisationen, Militär im Inneren.
Das sind einfach wirklich Unterschiede.
Und das sind fundamentale Unterschiede.
Und du siehst halt, auf welcher Seite sich halt irgendwie Jens Spahn,
das ist der Fraktionschef der stärksten
Regierungspartei, noch stärksten Regierungspartei in diesem Land.
Ja, es ist einfach absurd, was er von sich gibt und das ist auch einfach,
muss ich sagen, auch sehr schäbig in der deutschen Politik, dass auch hier,
wenn natürlich jetzt nicht im selben Maße wie das jetzt in den USA stattfindet,
aber trotzdem generell der Begriff Antifa im Verruf steht.
Ja also dass das erstmal so ein bisschen ehrenrührig ist, oh ja hier du bist
ja bei der Antifa gewesen, das betrifft ja dann auch viele linke Politiker und.
Das kann einfach nicht sein dass das Einsetzen für Antifaschismus,
was ja wie du richtig gesagt hast im Prinzip im Sinne prodemokratisch ist,
ja, dass das in irgendeiner Formen verunglimpft wird und man sieht es leider
bei der CDU auch schon seit längerem wie hieß hier nochmal unsere Klöckner ne
davor die andere Dame die,
auch schon dann gleich als sie antrat erstmal so Förderprogramme gegen für demokratische
Strukturen und Antifa Gruppen im Osten eingestellt hat und so also es ist immer.
So ein Wiederkehrend das Ding und irgendwie können sich einfach die Konservativen,
die haben einfach so einen totalen Rachekomplex mit Links.
Also für die ist einfach Links ja, das ist einfach so, die denken immer,
die müssen da unbedingt was dagegen tun, auch wenn das einfach ganz normale,
Aktivitäten sind und ganz normale Dinge, aber weil das halt irgendwie aus dem
linken Lager kommt und das sind ja immer die, die uns so kritisieren und so,
dann kann man die halt auch nicht irgendwie sein Und da ist halt auch dieser
Geist der Spaltung ist da immer zwischen den Zeilen.
Das ist das, was mich so furchtbar nervt, dass man einfach nicht über den Dingen
stehen kann und die Sachen mal objektiv sehen kann,
sondern jeder Kack und alles muss immer so für diese eigene Agenda und das eigene
Partisanship dann doch immer irgendwie mitgedacht werden.
Und es gibt einfach keinerlei Bereitschaft, mal in irgendeiner Form diese politische
Mitte auch wirklich zu sein, von der man immer redet, dass man sie ja angeblich vertreten würde.
Aber so ein Typ wie Spahn, der ist einfach nicht in der Mitte,
weil der nicht mit der Mitte redet und nichts für die Mitte tut.
Nein, das ist auf jeden Fall das ist auf jeden Fall nicht, bitte weil das sonst
in den Kommentaren ausgebreitet wird, zu Recht,
jetzt hat natürlich die sogenannte Antifa nicht immer,
Ideal im Sinne ihrer öffentlichen Wahrnehmung agiert.
Es gibt ein klassisches Erscheinungsbild, das ist dann so der schwarze Block
auf einer Demonstration.
Surfen an der Grenze des Vermummungsverbots. Mache jetzt auch nicht,
wenn sie so einen Block da durch die Straße laufen geht,
macht der wahrscheinlich keine besonders ja, wie würde man sagen,
keinen besonders erfreulichen Eindruck, wenn der da so lang geht.
Also die könnten, ich glaube, ein paar Hippies mit Blumen machen,
die hat man einfach lieber auf der Straße oder die sind leichter oder schwieriger zu diskreditieren.
Also klar, da ist für einen Teil ihres eigenen Rufes ist dann so der militante
Teil der Antifa auch selber verantwortlich.
Das hätte ich durchaus, was die PR-Perspektive auf dieses Verhalten angeht,
durchaus zwei, drei Verbesserungsvorschläge.
Entsprechend wurde ja aber dann auch, das machen Linke ja dann, die.
Kritisieren sich ja dann gegenseitig und stellen ihre Gemeinsamkeiten und Unterschiede
heraus Und dann wird halt gesagt, wir sind eine gewaltfreie Gruppierung.
Wir entglasen jetzt mal zum Beispiel am 1.
Mai nicht Kreuzberg, sondern wir gucken mal in Grunewald solche Ideen und machen
da vielleicht was Lustiges und so. Das gibt es ja dann alles.
Nur damit wir diese Kommentare nicht bekommen, das ist eben sicherlich eine ganze Reihe.
Nur weil an irgendetwas Antifa dran steht, heißt das ja nicht,
dass die gewählten Mittel ausgerechnet die richtigen sind und ich alles gut
heiße, wo Antifa dran steht.
Genauso wie, wenn ich jetzt Christ wäre, ich sicherlich nicht alles gut heißen würde.
Ganz besonders, wenn ich Christ wäre, würde ich garantiert nicht das Handeln
der christlichen demokratischen Union gut heißen.
Wenngleich sie sich auf meine christlichen Werte bezieht,
glaube ich, dass ich als Christ dann noch ein paar konstruktive Verbesserungsmöglichkeiten
Vorschläge hätte, wie man dem Christentum noch näher kommen könnte, als Jens Spahn.
Trotzdem weiß ich jetzt nicht, ob wir alle sagen würden, weil die CDU so unglaublich
fürchterlich ist, müssen wir jetzt alle Antichristen werden.
Damit habe ich den Bogen zu Peter Thiel geschlossen.
Aber wenn du Antifaschismus oder Antifa irgendwie als Terrororganisation,
diskreditierst, ist die Folge, dass Antifaschismus eben in Verruf gerät.
Und ich muss ehrlich sagen, dass ich
diesen Song von Team Scheiße Wenn du Anti-Antifa bist, dann bist du Fa.
Das ist halt, viele Texte von Team Scheiße, in die muss ich mich,
erst reintrinken, so vom Niveau.
Da erkenne ich jetzt nicht die Tiefe, da fehlt mir so ein bisschen noch die Tiefe in der Aussage.
Aber die Notwendigkeit dieser Aussage, das ist glaube ich das Einzige,
das Tatsächliche, was mich so fertig macht, dass man das heute den Leuten sagen muss.
Dass du halt in der Breite der Bevölkerung die Idee des Antifaschismus inzwischen
so weit diskreditiert hast, dass,
Dass sowas geht, ja.
Ja, ich glaube, es gibt auch einfach teilweise eben selbstverschuldet,
aber eben auch teilweise, glaube ich, auch medial verschuldet,
also da sehe ich, sagen wir mal, auch unsere Medien im Problembereich,
diese Wahrnehmung von Antifa als Organisation.
Wenn wir jetzt sagen, es gibt jetzt hier keine ladefähige Adresse,
das stimmt, das ist jetzt kein Verein oder so, so wie die AfD,
sondern Antifa ist erstmal eine Idee und zwar eine ganz gute Idee.
Aber das heißt nicht, dass sie sich nicht auch organisiert und das tut sie auch
und das tut sie in den Bereichen, in denen halt vor allem viel Fahr ist.
Und da wo dieses ganze Fahrzeug rumläuft, brauchst du auch eine Antifa,
einfach auch um Leute zu beschützen.
Also in Ostdeutschland, aber nicht nur da, einfach sagen wir mal in schwierigen Gegenden,
wo einfach auch die Neonazis so ein bisschen auch die Oberhand haben und wo
sich auch Jugendliche einfach bedroht fühlen,
weil sie sich entweder diesem vorherrschenden Duktus anpassen müssen,
um irgendwie zu überleben.
Oder in irgendeiner Form halt noch eine Flucht haben.
Entweder eine Flucht halt woanders hin, aber wenn das nicht möglich ist,
dann eben auch nur in Kreise, die in gewisser Hinsicht auch Schutz bieten können.
Und das ist halt stellenweise so, dass es dann eben kleine Antifa-Gruppen gibt,
die sich einfach zusammentun und die dann einfach auch ganz konkret Schutz bieten,
indem sie sich einfach gegenstellen gegen die Nazi-Schläger,
die versuchen, Andersdenkende.
Runterzumöbeln.
Und an der Stelle ist Antifa einfach eine Schutzfunktion, die die Leute zum
Beispiel bei der Polizei,
aber eben dann eben auch bei der Politik, die dann solche Jugendprojekte,
die das vielleicht fördern würden, dann nicht mehr finanzieren wollen, einfach nicht finden.
Und das ist eigentlich eine schreiende Ungerechtigkeit.
Und da muss man sich halt auch irgendwie nicht wundern, wenn die Dinge nicht
besser werden, wenn es einfach auch schon.
Nicht nur an finanziellem Support fehlt, das auch, aber vor allem auch an so einem,
moralischen Support. Wo ist denn der Aufruf, mal was gegen Nazis zu tun in Deutschland?
Das sind doch alles immer nur Sonntagsreden.
Ja, das geht ja nicht, das ist ja Gedankengut, das wollen wir hier nicht haben.
Aber wenn es dann mal irgendwie wieder,
um Polizeieinsätze geht, dann ist es einfach selten, wenn die Wannen auffahren,
dass ja einfach mal eine Nazi-Demo abgeräumt wird.
Das gibt es natürlich auch, aber es ist einfach meistens wird dann eher nur
ihr Marschweg gesichert und das ärgert mich einfach zutiefst,
dass diese Grundeinstellung da ist und dass es auch einfach keine Zeitung gibt.
Ein paar mag es geben, aber im Wesentlichen gibt es da nicht so diese Grundhaltung
mit so einer Erwartungshaltung, dass man sagt, ihr müsst solche Strukturen einfach
fördern und nicht in die Ecke stellen.
Machen wir mal. Also gerade das mit Schutz von Menschen, das sieht dann wieder keiner.
Das ist ja auch so der Klassiker.
Naja, genau, aber auch wenn dann, weißt du, dann hast du da halt irgendwie so
ein Nazi-Dorf und dann gibt es da irgendwie ein paar lokale Jugendliche oder
Menschen mit Zivilcourage,
die sich mal gerade machen und dann kriegen die halt auch mal einen auf die Fresse,
weil die jemanden schützen.
Oder dann sind irgendwo mal wieder in Rostock oder in Mölln und wo das nicht alles war,
dann irgendwelche rassistischen Pogrome und dann gibt es halt Leute,
die sagen, da fahre ich jetzt hin.
Das muss ja auch erst mal an dem Punkt, die meisten Leute haben ja gesagt,
guck mal hier im Fernsehen, das ist ja unglaublich, was da in Lichtenhagen los ist.
Und ein paar sind halt hin und haben gesagt, alles klar, dann versuchen wir
den Scheiß jetzt hier mal abzuräumen und irgendwie das umzusetzen,
was man uns gelehrt hat, wogegen wir diesen Staat verteidigen müssen.
Und Menschen zu schützen gegen Angriffe, gegen die sie kein anderer schützt.
Da muss dann erstmal der Bus beschlagnahmt werden.
Ja, ich weiß gar nicht, ob der Adenauer gerade, ich glaube gerade,
ich weiß echt gar nicht, ob der Adenauer gerade schon wieder irgendjemandem
weggenommen wurde oder nicht.
Ich verliere den Überblick. Unter deradenauer.de findet man es bestimmt.
Und, war das der Adenauer.de?
Ja, okay. Gut, also nochmal, das Problem ist, eine Idee zur Terrororganisation zu verhindern.
Umzubenennen, dazu zu definieren, ist wirklich so ein richtig krasser Move der Gedankenkontrolle.
Und damit wären wir auch schon beim nächsten Thema, Chatkontrolle.
Seit drei Jahren eines eurer Lieblingsthemen bei Logbuch Netzpolitik,
denn seit drei Jahren, das ist noch länger als drei Jahre, seit drei Jahren
streiten sich jetzt die EU-Institutionen im Trilog, denke ich mal schon.
Ja, es ist ja Ewigkeiten her, diese Idee, was ist die Idee, ich wiederhole es Die Idee ist,
Internetdienste zu verpflichten,
die Inhalte der Nutzenden auf strafbare Inhalte zu durchsuchen und bei Verdacht
an Behörden zu schicken.
Ja, die, und zwar strafbare Inhalte, wie immer, als allererstes geht es dann
um Kindesmissbrauch, dann kommt als nächstes Terrorismus und dann kommt irgendwie,
was weiß ich, Handtaschendiebstahl.
Strafbare Inhalte, also hier dokumentierter Kindesmissbrauch,
das wäre dann eben eine Medienformat, ja, Bild,
aber auch potenziell die Idee einer Anbahnung, das wären also dann auch Kommunikationsinhalte.
Und wir haben hier in den Sendungen der vergangenen Jahre, glaube ich,
öfter mal erklärt, wie kann man ein Bild erkennen.
Da hat sich seitdem auch technisch nochmal einiges weiterentwickelt und entsprechend
soll das natürlich jetzt mit einer AI stattfinden.
Also eine AI soll über deine Kommunikationsinhalte wachen, wenn du nicht eh
schon deine Sexting-Messages von ChatGPT schreiben lässt.
Kriegst du die dann jetzt von ChatGPT gelesen oder von einer davor auf trainierten
AI, die die Inhalte dann ausleitet an eine zentrale,
Überwachungsstelle der Strafverfolgungsbehörden.
Also richtig krasse Idee. Und,
Darüber diskutieren wir jetzt seit Längerem. Das EU-Parlament sagt,
das ist Maßenüberwachung und das geht so nicht.
Eine Einschränkung wäre eben nur, wenn die Kommunikation unverschlüsselt ist
und nur bei einem Verdacht dürfe diese Technologie zum Einsatz kommen.
Kommissionen will, wie gesagt, hier alle Internetdienste gleichermaßen,
auch bei insbesondere bei verschlüsselter Kommunikation, weil da können wir
nicht mehr zentral überwachen.
Jetzt haben sie, ich weiß nicht wie viele Ratspräsidentschaften,
niemand hat das hingekriegt, jetzt ist Dänemark.
Die Ratspräsidentschaft, die Sozialdemokraten aus Dänemark, die finden das gut,
die wollen diese verpflichtete Chat-Kontrolle inklusive eben,
Client-Side-Scanning, das heißt Also noch auf deinem Gerät findet das statt,
weil das ist die, in Anführungszeichen,
Lösung für verschlüsselte Messenger, dass du dann die Inhalte eben prüfst vor
dem Absenden oder nach dem Empfang, also entschlüsselt.
Und jetzt sagt Dänemark, ja okay, hier in dieser Runde der Justiz- und Innenminister
wollen wir dann am 14. Oktober mal den Entwurf annehmen.
Bisher, also die letzte Ratspräsidentschaft hatte gesagt, ja,
pass auf, lass das Ganze doch mal freiwillig machen statt verpflichten und nicht
auf verschlüsselte Kommunikation.
Dann hat Dänemark gesagt, ja, nö, das machen wir jetzt rückgängig und bieten,
quasi diesen alten Entwurf nochmal an. Also sie haben gar nichts mehr geändert.
Also der, also dieser,
Kompromissfindungsprozess besteht jetzt darin, dass sie einfach nichts mehr
ändern und mit dem Holzhammer immer wieder draufkloppen und warten,
dass sich irgendwann mal die Mehrheitsverhältnisse ändern, dass es irgendeiner annimmt.
Das ist auch übrigens ja.
Auch so ein Demokratieverständnis, was ja, davon zeugt, dass sie die demokratischen
Prozesse verstanden haben.
Nämlich, dass sich Mehrheit irgendwann mal ändern und dann mache ich das halt wieder.
Deswegen diskutierst du Dinge halt über Jahrzehnte.
Also über Jahrzehnte wird gesagt, hier Vorratsdatenspeicherung,
Vorratsdatenspeicherung, Vorratsdatenspeicherung, Chatkontrolle,
Chatkontrolle, Chatkontrolle.
Wenn du sagst, wie wert man mit Vermögenssteuer, sagt nein. Nein.
Chatkontrolle, Chatkontrolle, Chatkontrolle. Aber sonst, also so funktionieren
demokratische Prozesse.
Und jetzt sagen sie halt, okay, wir schlagen das wieder vor.
Und jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, jetzt dürfen EU-Staaten nochmal dann schriftliche
Kommentare und Anmerkungen einreichen, dann am 9. Oktobertag nochmal die Arbeitsgruppe und am 14.
Sollen dann eben Justiz und Innenminister dem alten Entwurf einfach zustimmen
und sagen, scheiße, der muss jetzt endlich mal vom Tisch.
Wäre natürlich auch schön gewesen, das einfach so mal vom Tisch zu legen und
zu sagen, okay, scheint offenbar eine Idee zu sein, bei der wir noch nicht mal
einen Kompromiss finden, aber nein, das ist jetzt hier der Weg.
Dafür, ich glaube, die Mehrheit dagegen ist enorm gering und ich würde vermuten,
wenn jetzt Deutschland seine Positionierung ändern würde,
dann kann Deutschland dem Ding halt zu einer Mehrheit verhelfen.
Oder auch irgendein anderer Staat jetzt wird natürlich in den Analysen muss
man jetzt in jeden einzelnen Staat schauen wer macht da jetzt was,
wie verhalten die sich und so, jetzt darfst du auch nicht vergessen,
dass unser Innenminister ist Dobrindt.
Und unser Kanzler ist Friedrich Merz.
Da muss ich schon sagen, dass man jetzt da ein bisschen nervös werden kann.
Dann haben wir noch einen Digitalminister, der sagt, er würde sich in diesen
politischen Prozess nicht von der Seitenlinie einbringen.
Das ist zumindest verständlich, Ich weiß, das ist jetzt nicht unbedingt sein
Metier, aber er ist ja zumindest mal derjenige, der ein bisschen Ahnung von Digitalem hat.
Insofern könnte er ja mal seine Meinung sagen. Ich meine, Jens Spahn sagt ja
auch zu jedem Scheiß seine Meinung.
Das wäre ganz gut, aber er ist so busy, weißt du? Der muss ja erstmal ein Ministerium
aufbauen und Leute finden und so weiter. Ich glaube, der ist...
Nicht, dass er nicht seine Meinung sagen könnte, wäre ja schon mal ganz gut
zu wissen, ob er überhaupt eine
hat zu dem Thema. Das fände ich ja an sich schon mal ganz interessant.
Andererseits ist er natürlich als Quereinsteiger aus der Wirtschaft,
wie wir wissen, in diesem politischen Prozess eine Nullnummer.
Also diese politische Cloud hat er einfach nicht in irgendeiner Form sich durchsetzen
zu können. Also das würde mich auf jeden Fall sehr überraschen.
Nichtsdestotrotz könnte er natürlich auch eine öffentliche Diskussion darum
mal ein bisschen bereichern. Das tut er definitiv nicht.
Seine Ankündigungen sind derzeit auch alle eher so im Fragestil als im Antwortstil.
Hintergrund ist natürlich, warum geben sie sich damit Mühe, auch das haben wir
öfter hier behandelt, es gibt ja die E-Privacy-Richtlinie, die nämlich genau
das, was die Chat-Kontrolle macht, verbietet.
Da haben sie eine vorübergehende Ausnahme gemacht, in der Hoffnung dann das Ganze zu verpflichten.
Also damit wird es überhaupt erstmal erlaubt, so etwas zu tun. Es ist quasi verboten.
Jetzt läuft diese Ausnahme im April 26 aus.
Das ist aber nicht das erste Mal, dass sie ausläuft, weil sie schon mal die
Ausnahme verlängert haben.
Aber das nutzt natürlich jetzt Dänemark mal wieder, um diesen,
Druck aufrechtzuerhalten. Und dann.
Laut dem Artikel von André Meister, wie immer exzellent, fünf Staaten lehnen
den dänischen Vorschlag ab.
Polen unterstützt den Kampf gegen sexuellen Missbrauch.
Dafür muss Prävention verstärkt werden.
Niederlande und Luxemburg unterstützen ebenfalls das Ziel, aber nicht die Mittel-Tschechien,
sagt auch, ist nicht verhältnismäßig.
Österreich verweist auf seine bereits bekannte und unveränderte Position,
die hat uns vor drei Jahren abgelehnt und daran ist die Bundesregierung gebunden.
Tja, Schweden prüft Finnland, schaut als ambivalent drauf, Slowakei prüft.
Lettland sagt es gut. Also da ist halt am Ende eine ganze Menge auf Deutschland Schultern.
Bisher war Deutschland dagegen. Und jetzt können wir sehen. Also Dobrindt will
das gerne aufweichen. Ja.
Und wenn Deutschland kippt, dann haben wir es.
Meinst du, dass Deutschland alleine reicht?
Ja, ja, ich meine das nicht, ich lese das hier. Wenn André das schreibt, dann stimmt das.
Okay.
Ich hatte es ohnehin, also ich hatte es vorhin, deswegen habe ich jetzt gerade
in den Artikel geschaut, weil es mir so war.
Ja.
Und ja.
Tja.
So, und jetzt?
Tja. Wir werden hoffen, dass Deutschland das jetzt nicht verkackt.
Hoffen auf Deutschland.
Dann wird jetzt die elektronische Patientenakte, das ist aber eher so ein Nebenthema,
die ist ja schon eingeführt worden, das waren ja aber so nach und nach Pilotphasen.
Also erstmal gab es so die Einführungsphase, da konnten die Leistungserbringer
freiwillig daran teilnehmen.
Dann haben im Januar die Krankenkassen für alle Versicherten,
die nicht widersprochen haben, so eine Akte angelegt.
Dann fing das an in Hamburg, Franken,
Nordrhein-Westfalen, Teile von Nordrhein-Westfalen, diese Pilotphase und dann
wurde sie jetzt schrittweise bundesweit ausgerollt und jetzt ist so der Moment,
dass sie von wurde ausgerollt und ist jetzt verfügbar, langsam in die Richtung
geht, dass sie sagen, jetzt muss auch wirklich jeder mitmachen.
Und ich glaube, im nächsten Jahr wird es dann für die Leistungserbringer schwierig,
dass sie dann sagen, kriegst du weniger Geld, wenn du da nicht mitmachst und so.
Also, tja, jetzt ist der, ich meine, wenn du nicht mit solchen Methoden arbeiten
würdest, um so eine Technologie dann auch wirklich in die Breite zu zwingen,
dann würde sie halt auch niemals dort ankommen.
Insofern ist das sicherlich jetzt für die Ärztinnschaft ärgerlich,
aber für das Projekt notwendig.
Unsere Kritik konzentriert sich ja größtenteils auf die absolut inakzeptable
Qualität der Umsetzung.
Katastrophale, nicht erläuterbare Schutzmaßnahmen.
Ich würde in dem Kontext nochmal unsere Folge mit Bianca empfehlen,
da hat sich nichts dran geändert, inhaltlich und technisch.
Es ist halt traurig, wenn die technische Basis halt so ein Murks ist.
Da kann ich auch, also ich behandle das manchmal so in Gesprächen oder als Beispiele
von, wie viel Papier kannst du zusammenschreiben, um ein Sicherheits- und ein
Betriebskonzept zu machen.
Und dann, wir erinnern uns, dass diese Fraunhofer-Leute bei ihrer Sicherheitsprüfung
dann noch nicht mal mehr gelesen haben, sondern halt eine LLM da drauf geworfen
haben, weil sie meinten, es ist viel zu kompliziert.
Und am Ende, das ist völlig normal, das ist ja hier.
Das ist ja hier.
Ja, weißt du, wenn jemand sagt, hier ist das sicher,
und sagen dir, ja gib mal her und dann geben die dir so viel Papier,
dass du sagst, das können wir nicht lesen, das müssen wir jetzt in ein LLM trainieren
und dann fragen wir das, ja, an dem Punkt hätte man ja, also sag ich mal,
das ist so der Test, dass man sagt, okay, wenn dieses Sicherheitskonzept nicht
für uns als Prüfer überblickbar und verständlich ist, dann ist ja die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
dass das jemand korrekt implementiert,
sehr gering.
Insofern hätte man das an dem Moment zurückschicken müssen. Aber ne,
die wollten natürlich Gematik-GPT.
Ja, ja.
Das ist wirklich ein solches Problem, Tim, dass die Menschheit gerade in ihrer
Sehnsucht nach einfachen Regeln für alles so eine Vorgabe haben will.
Und dass sie vor lauter Vorgabe wirklich alle das Denken einstellen,
und ich würde mich jetzt auch inzwischen wirklich als Bürokratie-Skeptiker einstufen,
wenn Leute irgendwie für jede Eventualität irgendeine Regel formulieren wollen und dabei vergessen,
dass es natürlich Eintrittswahrscheinlichkeiten und Risiken gibt und dass man
sich lieber um die Risiken kümmert, als möglichst viel Scheiße aufzuschreiben,
um gegen jede Eventualität gerüstet zu sein.
Und dann eben vergessen, dass man vielleicht einen ordnungsgemäßen Zugriffsschutz
für diese Daten braucht.
Wie kannst du das, wie kannst du das übersehen?
War das nicht auch der Till der Sendung mit Bianca, you had one job?
Wenn nicht, dann ist es der Unter-Till.
Ja, traurig. Aber können wir dann demnächst das LLM nicht nur mit dem Sicherheitskonzept
trainieren, sondern mit den Inhalten der Patientenakten?
Hat aber, benutzt ja eh noch keiner, insofern da,
stabilisiert sich dann die deutsche Mentalität wieder. Schrott bauen,
aber skeptisch sein, am Ende wird das Ding nach 10 Jahren eingestellt und wurde
nie irgendwas reingetan. Genauso wie mit der D-Mail.
Hohe einstellige Anzahl D-Mails, die da am Tag versendet wurde.
Vielleicht wird das ja auch so ein Rohrkrepierer.
Und dann können wir am Ende dem Datenschutz die Schuld geben.
Der Datenschutz ist immer schuld.
So, dann wollen wir noch einen Termin ankündigen. Wir wurden nämlich...
Zwei.
Nee.
Doch, ich hab auch noch einen.
Das steht nicht in den Shownotes. Wo denn? Da drunter. Die sind gleichzeitig.
Ja, man muss ja auch Optionen haben.
Ja, dann fang du mal an.
Ich soll anfangen? Okay. Also, am Samstag, den 4.
Oktober, findet der zweite Berliner Fediverse-Tag oder Fediverse-Day statt.
Netzwerkevent für Menschen im Fediversum.
Gibt viele Vorträge, Workshops und so weiter und ganz viel Networking.
Sind auch ein paar Meta-Ebene Gäste und Allstars mit Vorträgen vertreten.
Von daher sehr zu empfehlen. Wer also Lust hat, da mitzumachen am Samstag.
Das fängt irgendwie um 12 Uhr an und geht irgendwie bis in die Puppen.
Berlin-Feddy.de gibt es alle Informationen, Tickets und so weiter.
Und am gleichen Tag, wer dann näher an der Palz ist,
nämlich in Stuttgart, ist näher dran.
Ja, ja, ja.
Würde ich jetzt vermuten.
Hat mir die schon mal irgendwas mit Oberpfalz oder so?
Ich weiß es nicht, ist ja auch egal. Also wer in Stuttgart ist oder dahin möchte.
Ja.
Stuttgart wird ja gerade von den Grünen und der CDU regiert und,
das muss ich wirklich vorlesen, was uns Alex da schreibt, in den Koalitionsverhandlungen
wurde der Einsatz von Palantir von der CDU mit den Grünen gegen einen etwas
größeren Nationalpark im Schwarzwald getauscht.
Unserer Meinung nach ein richtig schlechter Tausch. Das Investorium hatte für
ungefähr 25 Millionen Euro die Software Gotham,
über eine Anschlussklausel im Rahmenvertrag des Landes Bayerns mit Palantir gekauft.
Gesetzesgrundlage fehlt. Die wollen sie nun im Oktober schaffen.
Und dann haben sie eine Gesetzesänderung im Gesetz zur Einführung einer automatisierten
Datenanalyse und zur Änderung weiterer polizeirechtlicher Vorschriften und da
verschärfen sie eben das Polizeigesetz.
Die grüne Basis findet das nicht so geil, Kreis- und Ortsverbände haben Beschlüsse
gegen den Einsatz von Palantir in Baden-Württemberg.
Es gibt auch einen Musterbeschluss und so weiter nach einem Treffen von engagierten
Leuten haben wir viel Zulauf und deswegen wird es eine Demonstration am 4.10.
Das ist der gleiche Oktober Berlin Fedi Day am Schlossplatz in Stuttgart geben,
aufpassen, Schlossplatz Stuttgart ist das in der Nähe von dem Hauptbahnhof,
der Hauptbahnhof ist immer noch verhüllt,
den haben sie auch nicht fertig gekriegt.
Immerhin kriegst du nicht mehr das Augenlicht genommen, wenn du da irgendwie
bist an dem Bahnhof da haben sie ja damals in den Demonstrationen dagegen haben sie den Leuten mit dem,
das ist eine Verkehrsstörung, ja gut, das ist natürlich auch immer in Stuttgart
so ich guck gerade, wo der Schlossplatz,
Ist das der da am Oberer Schlossgarten?
Schlossgarten heißt das. Wo ist denn jetzt der Schlossplatz?
Der Schlossplatz ist im Zentrum.
Ja, Hauptsache ich muss nicht an diesen...
Beim Schloss ist der. Wo sollte der sonst sein?
Ja, wahrscheinlich. Aber hat das Schloss einen eigenen Bahnhof oder muss ich da durch diesen...
Naja, das ist wichtig für die Reiseplätze. Planung, wenn du da...
Der Schlossplatz ist schon noch mal so eine U-Bahn-Station weg vom Hauptbahnhof.
Das ist gut.
Hauptsache nicht am Hauptbahnhof.
Kann man aber auch irgendwie hinfahren.
Gut.
Das war's, oder?
Jetzt weiß ich nicht genau, ob das... Ja doch. Es wäre natürlich zu schwer.
Wir haben ja zwei Lieder zur Wahl. Bleiben Sie dran.
Und hören Sie jetzt, wie Tim Prittler sich entscheidet, nimmt er diesmal das
richtige Peilslied oder hat er nochmal ein Falsches gefunden oder nimmt er doch
Team Scheiße als Bonus-Track.
Es bleibt spannend.
Das ist unglaublich.
Cliffhanger.
Cliffhanger. Tschüss Leute, bis dann.
Ciao, ciao.